المشاهدين الى الشان الامريكي وحول ازمه
سقف الدين يلتقي الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ورئيس مجلس النواب كيفن ماكارتي في البيت
الابيض في لحظه محوريه تشهد مصارعه في
واشنطن للتوصل الى حل وسط بشان الميزانيه
ورفع الحد الاقتراض في الوقت المناسب
لتجنب تعثر فيدرالي مدمر من جانبه قلم
كارتي ان مكالمته الهاتفيه الاخيره مع
بايدن كانت مثمره وان المفاوضات بين
موظفيه وممثلين بيت الابيض تركز على خفض
الانفاق
لكن مشاهدينا يبقى سؤال مهم ماذا سيحدث
للعالم لو لم تسدد الولايات المتحده
ديونها في الوقت المحدد غالبيه المصادر
اتفقت على ان التاثير على الولايات
المتحده سيفوق ما حدث في عام 2011 حينما
اخرت الحكومه قرار رفع سقف الدين ليومين
قبل نفاذ الاموال على المدى القصير ستخسر
الولايات المتحده نصف مليون وظيفه وسينخفض
اقتصادها بنحو 0.6 بالمئه من ناتجها
القومي فيما على النطاق العالمي فتجب هنا
معرفه ثقل الخزانه والديون الامريكيه في
الاقتصاد العالمي لمعرفه الاثر المخيف
لعدم السداد فنحو 500 مليار دولار من
السندات الامريكيه يتم تداولها يوميا في
سوق السندات وتشكل الاسهم الامريكيه ما
نسبته 60% من قيمه الاسهم في العالم لذلك
فان اقل ما يقال عن تاثير التخلف عن
السداد انه
كارثي على الاقتصاد العالمي لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات